nisar pendant tout le spectacle je me
gratte je me gratte c'est tout enfin
quand je dis c'est tout c'est énorme
naturellement c'est très violent très
engagé comme tous quelque chose dans la
pièce à je suis une bourgeoise oui bien
sûr une bourgeoise ça c'est herman
exprimé par l'odeur de boules puantes
qu'on jette dans la salle dès le début
ainsi chaque soir au moment où ils
entrent en scène c'est une idée de trucs
le vétéran l'espace fantastique
vous saisissez l'équation le raccourci
j'arrive je pu donc je suis une
bourgeois c'est fabuleux
alors naturellement she's gone incapable
de prononcer un mot mais une conne
disgrâce
parce qu'elle est conne parce qu'elle se
sent mal dans sa peau
parce que parce qu'enfin tout c'est
fantastique
1h30 2h 2h30 je sais pas peu importe si
on s'en fout ça va tellement plus loin
la ligne ont fait durer quatre heures
ça aurait pu durer toute la nuit ça
peut-être durer toute l'année je ne sais
pas je sais plus j'en suis là entre le
public et moi
vic très jeune très chouette il y avait
une telle complicité une telle
connivence c'était fantastique
fantasque je me suis levé les yeux au
jeune comme ça simplement d'un seul coup
j'ai eu envie je sais pas ça me
paraissait très chouette et vraiment ça
a été très chouette
j'étais là au milieu d'eux il y avait
une telle chaleur un tel contact à la
fin tout le monde se grattait tout le
monde ratait tout le monde même un
moment il ya un tipi ce pardon à la
rentrée à vous pouvez bien sûr je crée
la nouvelle pièce de choses le troisième
volet de sa trilogie
alors là je crois qu'il est difficile
d'aller plus loin je te les dix on se
tutoie je suis plus sûr citoyens très
con c'est le troisième volet tu voit
l'aboutissement c'est assez terrifiant
mais si tu veux essayer de te dire enfin
c'est pas facile alors je suis là
bourgeoise bien sûr mais arrivé au
dernier stade tu vois
à poil complètement à poil très belle tu
vois mais à l'intérieur complètement
pourrie elle est là à poil et puis il ya
un jeune qui passa poids serait chouette
très dur très dur ce tu vois on a fait
ça tout de suite et il me crachent enfin
dans la gueule et durant toute la pièce
tu vois on assiste à la descente du
saumon tard depuis les yeux jusqu'au
sénat c'est arrivé de la salive en fait
purificatrices et avant cette lente
descente celle angoisse le malaise
si tu veux je me suis parlons d'autre
chose je me sens pas très bien c'est un
rôle qui engage terriblement ce tas rôle
très très lourd à assumer